à 71 ans marie-julie granomort travaille
toujours
et si son médecin le docteur mcneil lui
a proposé de faire un dosage de
chlordécone dans le sang c'est pour une
raison simple elle est ouvrière agricole
aux lorrains depuis l'adolescence est un
hymne à l'amour 5,60 10 microgrammes par
litre de sang
un taux qui la place parmi les plus
élevés marie-julie fera maintenant
l'objet d'une surveillance particulière
de son médecin
mais sa démarche reste minoritaire est
ce qu a dit c'est que les goûts à vigny
points 12 âge là me suis dit 'ça y op et
opu parfaite d'animaux des cayes médecin
n'attaquera pas des dix à qinze libye et
des migrants mardi dans son corps toutes
munies ça c'est calliopée ne parlions
pas les faits ça il faut dire aussi que
le test coûte 140 euros non remboursés
le docteur mcnee qui propose ce test à
la plupart de ses patients n'a obtenu
outre marie julie que trois réponses
positives
j'en attends casey au chlordécone a une
autre qui à 0,18 microgrammes
un agriculteur qui cultive et qui mange
c'est la chaîne qui à 2,41 microgrammes
ce sensible la médecine environnementale
et que l'impact des pesticides sur le
corps est bien connue au centre hot
bonjour veille avec quoi ce sont les
labos du réseau biolab qui traite sans
ordonnance les dosages de chlordécone
les prélèvements sont faits ici puis
envoyés à limoges le délai de retour et
de trois semaines des analyses qui
pourraient être réalisées sur place on
pourrait faire des invisibles ce qu'on a
une compétence technique on est habitué
à traiter du sang et à manier des
automates
le problème étant si vous voulez que le
coût des machines pour faire ces
analyses est relativement élevé et étant
donné que les annonces de pesticides
sont souvent
non remboursés par la sécurité sociale
même si la demande commence à poindre
il n'y a pas le flux si vous voulez pour
permettre
d'installer ces machines ici certaines
associations comme l'âme cesse milite
pour un dépistage beaucoup plus
généralisée les dernières analyses de l'
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
place le risque cancer pour les hommes
notamment un taux de chlordécone très
bas un homme de 44 ans une fois que vous
avez plus de 0,00 19 microgrammes par
litre de chlordécone dans le sens vous
avez vous commencé à courir un risque
c'est à dire que si vous continuez à
être exposés au chlordécone à partir de
cette ode à votre risque de cancer de la
prostate augmente selon ces chiffres 3
des patients testés du docteur mekni
sont donc à risque
le labo n'a pour l'instant eu à traiter
que quatorze demandes de dosage